[Music]
sharon's in san antonio hi sharon
welcome to the ramsay show
hey guys dave pleasure to speak with you
i appreciate your time thank you so much
i um i'm in a position where i'm able to
pay off my ex-husband's house for him
why and i was wondering if you thought
that would be a good idea well it sounds
weird
who pays off their ex-husband's house
he's a really really really good man and
he he deserves a break he needs kind of
a hand
um
up and i just wanted to help him i'm i
um so is george just send him the money
i will take it a lot of good people out
there you could give to
so that's some strange generosity yeah
that's different
is that weird i don't know no it's okay
it's just it's i mean if you want to do
it i'm not mad at you it's just would
you have to admit it's highly unusual
yeah like i don't think in 30 years i've
ever gotten this call
oh okay yeah i'm not trying to buy his
affection i don't want to get back
together with him he's just a good man
so how much do you how much does he owe
on his house
135 and you have like extra 135 000
laying around
yeah i have four and a half million in
assets plus a trust fund that's two
million
okay
um oh can by the way i'm working with
one of your endorsed local providers
here in san antonio can i say his name
uh jeff whalen and the whaling wealth
team fabulous that's awesome how long
have you been divorced
um we got divorced in 2016.
we were married for 18 years
no children
um where did you get all this money
where'd all this money come from
um my my parents and then and then they
passed away and my brother was sitting
on it and then he passed away
in 2020 and then he did not have a will
so i had a heck of a mess on my hands
so i had um
excuse me everything went to me
um and uh so that was that so you're
like what 50 you're 50 something years
old
i'm 53 years old yesterday and what do
you do for a living
i have a part-time job i do customer
service over the phone for
a company here in san antonio okay
all right
um
well there's nothing
legally wrong with this there's nothing
morally wrong with this there's nothing
um
uh mathematically wrong with this you
have the money you won't even notice
out of four
five million dollars losing
giving up 135 000.
um
i think it's just suffice it to say it's
just strange enough that
um from a relational standpoint or an
emotional standpoint you know you might
want to talk this through with like your
pastor
i'm not saying don't do it but you have
to admit that it's weird and and you
know it's just it is and so
if you want to go do it that's fine
so you know i don't know yeah i mean i
guess i'd i'd wonder his situation
financially is he good at money
management is this going to make him
feel like he just got a free ticket uh
if he hasn't been handling his money
well you don't want to be enabling in
that situation but
i mean it sounds like he's got a normal
mortgage like a normal person and she
just wants to rid him of it
but i'm still taking a nice long pause
before i catch the check
i just think of a whole lot of things
i'm putting line in front of it if it
was me doing it but you know you have a
sweetheart honey there's no question
about that and
um it's your money and you're not doing
anything wrong and
even if it's unusual it's okay to do it